Welcome to the show.
It is a new year and I want to talk just a
little bit about my plan for 2020 not specifically
about election coverage.
We'll talk about that later, but, but a little
more generally about what's going on in American
political society.
One of the goals that I have for 2020 for
the show is to do everything I can to reverse
the Hypernormalization of radical unhinged
behavior and actions.
And it's, it's been really tough.
I mean we've talked about this before and
sometimes people will call in about it.
We've experienced all of us a sort of desensitization
and normalization under Donald Trump where
every norm, countless ethics rules, the way
we talk about politics, the way we do diplomacy,
the way we interact with other world leaders
and countries, it's all gone out the window.
And between the scandal, fatigue and being
desensitized, we all to a degree start to
see crazy stuff as less crazy than we would
have in years past or even six months ago.
So today I want to talk about just a real
issue and I want to do it carefully.
And that issue is how do more people not care
that the president of the United States is
mentally unwell.
Or we can use the term mentally ill and I
want to be careful.
I don't want to stigmatize mental illness
because it doesn't deserve to be stigmatized.
I don't want to laugh at mental illness because
it's not a laughing matter.
Nor do I want to conflate things that shouldn't
be conflated.
So for example, being ignorant about politics
and economics as our president is, is not
mental illness.
It's not mental instability.
It's two different things.
Being a cheater in relationships and golf
and business is not mental illness.
Being an immoral person is not mental illness.
Lacking empathy is not mental illness, but
these things can be connected to mental illness.
And the fact that too many people seem uninterested
in recognizing that Donald Trump is mentally
unwell is a very bad sign for society.
There's a recent piece in salon that I encourage
you to read, uh, by Chauncey de Vega, where
Chauncey says, six societies normalize the
abberant and abhorrent behavior of their leaders
and other elites.
That behavior in turn becomes a pathology
of sorts, which infects the general public.
This has infected Trumpists.
Many of them, not all, some of them have ulterior
motives.
We're hearing regularly from the mental health
community more and more about this man who
is in charge of the country.
We've heard from psychiatry professor, dr
John Gartner on the program multiple times,
who told us the various conditions that Donald
Trump may have.
These are not jokes.
This is not making fun.
This is not being hyperbolic.
This is a red alert.
We have a mentally ill president, psychiatry
professor, dr bandy, Lee, uh, from Yale said
recently that Nancy Pelosi could have Donald
Trump and voluntarily evaluated because he
may be a threat to public safety.
Now, whether she actually can do it or not,
and whether Trump would would submit to that,
it's unlikely.
But this is an argument that another mental
health professional is making.
And immediately bandy Lee was excoriated by
the Trumpist.
Right?
How dare we inquire about the mental health
of the president.
We then have psychiatrist, Justin Frank who
says Trump is terrified, angry, and extremely
dangerous.
And that conflict quote gives him life.
There have been other leading mental health
professionals who have described Donald Trump
as psychotic.
Now psychotic.
We've got to be careful with this stuff.
Psychotic is often used colloquially in society
to mean a wacky or eccentric or quirky person.
Mental health professionals are using the
term medically.
Psychosis is a severe mental disorder in which
thought and emotions are so impaired.
That contact is lost with external reality.
That is in line with much of what the people
around Donald Trump had been reporting is
going on.
Chauncey de Vega goes on to write in his salon
piece that we are seeing now, something that
relates to what philosopher Henry [inaudible]
described as a dis imagination machine.
This is a really important concept.
The dissemination machine is the apparatus
that includes images, institutions, discourse,
media, political movements, parties.
It prevents people from properly bearing witness
to phenomena and to remembering those phenomena
in a way that applies critical thinking and
a critique.
It prevents people from being critically informed.
Even the ways in which we are talking about
Donald Trump's behavior sort of is doing this.
I'll give you an example.
When we say Trump's behavior is unreal, there's
an implied meaning, which is we mean that
it's outrageous behavior.
We mean that it's unacceptable behavior that
it has to be stopped.
But when we use the word unreal, it also implies
it's not real.
It's not really happening the way that it
appears to be.
And Donald Trump has pushed this.
Remember Donald Trump said, what you are seeing
and reading is not actually happening.
It's not actually real.
So Chauncey de Vega's conclusion is that when
we talk about is fascism coming, is totality,
totalitarianism, whatever.
We won't know it because it will become the
new normal.
Very slowly.
Just like having a mentally ill president
increasingly has become the norm.
Many Republicans don't care because they've
got, they've got their judges in, they're
getting their nominations installed, they're
getting stuff done while the focus is on Donald
Trump.
They just pretend that Donald Trump is okay,
but for too many people, they have actually
fallen into this normalization.
2020 is going to be a real test for the country.
I'm going to avoid, uh, I'm going to try to
do my part better said to avoid the continued
normalization of what is mentally ill behavior.
Without conflating that with just an ignorant
president with an immoral president, with
an unethical president, these are different
issues.
We are not going to stigmatize mental illness,
but at a certain point when this number of
mental health professionals are sounding the
alarm and half the country seems not to care
or simply to refuse to see reality, it is
starting to infect the country exactly the
way that Chauncey de Vega writes in salon.
We're going to link to that piece in the description
for the YouTube clip for this story.
And I want to hear from you about this.
Uh, let's talk
a little
bit now about moving on from in general, my
goal in in 2020, uh,